learn how to build a complete fullstack
project in asp.net core asp.net core is
a high performance open- Source
framework for building modern
cloud-based Internet connected
applications such as web apps iot apps
and Mobile backends using.net in this
course Alan omary will teach you how to
build an auction web application hi
there everyone welcome back to another
YouTube series in this series we are
going to create a complete application
in asp.net core we're are going to build
an auctions application where every user
can create a listing and the user who
bits the highest amount will win in the
moment that the listings owner decides
to close the bidding each user will have
the option to see its own listings and
the listings he has bid it for by simply
going to the corresponding Link in the
navigation menu many different features
will be implemented in this project such
as adding comments in the listings
Details page pagination uploading image
files in a project making changes to the
pages depending on the user currently
logged in and many
more in this first section we're going
to create the project and we're going to
add the models needed for our
application we will then connect our
project to the database and this way we
will have the fundamental set up to
continue to build our
project so firstly we need to create a
new project
and we need to find here a template for
an MVC
application just type your
MVC and just click on this
one go next uh we can name our project
here I name it just
options go to the next
page and here we need to make the
authentication type to individual
accounts so that we have these users
already enabled in our uh project when
it loads this way we have the users
functionality already uh being taken
care
of okay so the first thing we want to do
is go to models and start adding classes
or
models to uh for our models needed for
the project let me just name the first
model
first model is going to be the main one
which is the listing so for each listing
that our application will
have and I'm going to give it an public
in ID
property and then for each listing we're
going to need a
title to be a
string
and of course uh we need the description
for each
listing uh we're going to need a double
property for the price of the listing
that we will put there here we need a
string property for image path so
basically when an image will be uploaded
for a listing it will be stored inside
the folder in our project and for for us
to call the image of a specific listing
we will use then the path where the
image is stored but you will see it
later on how this all
works then we're going to need the E Sal
of bull property
because this way we will specify if
listing is already sold or not and we
will not display the sold listings in
the first page and also some other
functionalities will depend end of if a
listing is solved or
not then we're going to connect we need
to connect each listing to the uh
user and we'll need an identity user ID
which is the property of types
chain firstly and we need here to
specify the object we will connect the
leaks thing to the model which is
identity user and we'll name it
user so we'll make them
nullable and we need to specify here the
foreign key for the user which will be
this identity user ID so this identity
user we're already installed when we
made the individual
accounts to uh when we created a
project basically each listing will be
created by specific user so that's why
uh we need this
two properties
here and on top we're going to make this
as required so basically what this does
is whenever a user is deleted for
example uh we won't be able to see the
listing anymore because that's uh how it
would make sense so if a user is not
anymore in my application
we won't see the listings as well the
listings will be deleted from
database and in the end we're going to
need to connect the listings so one
listing will have multiple bits made to
it and we will create this uh this model
now a bit later and also each uh each
listing will help multiple comments to
it and we'll create the comments model
also uh
next and this is the way we store them
when we uh write this type of models
when they are one to many relationship
models so let me create the next model
that we
need the b. CS
model first I'm going need an in ID
property and then a double property for
the
price let just copy this because each
bid has also need to be connected to a
user who made the bid and if the user is
no longer there the bid will be created
deled so if the user is deleted the bid
will be
deleted and we will also need to connect
each bit to a
listing so first we need a listing ID
property and then a listing
property just calling it
listing and
I would need to make both of them as
notable and here we specify the forign
key which is listing
ID let me just create the
next model that we need which is going
to be the comment. Cs the comment
model okay so as usual we need an in ID
property I in string property for the
content of the
comment
and I'm just going to copy this again
this identity user ID and the user the
identity user property so just like by
on the bits I'm actually going to copy
this from the bid model because just
like with bids we connect the comment
with the user and with the listing so
they have to be connected to to user and
the listing
and just copy that down and that now
what we're going to need to do is go to
the context which was already created by
default when we created a project and we
need to specify the DB set inst
instances for each model that we created
so dbet listing which I name
listings and we're going to do the same
thing for all the three models that we
created
so D set
bid nameing it
bids and the Deb
set for the
comment and I name it
comments so now uh when we go to app
settings. Json we have a a default
database connection there but we're
going to need need to create a new
database actually and go here and create
new database let me just open SQL Server
management Studio to get this uh server
name okay let me just copy
this I'm just going to paste it here and
give a name to the database like
auctions data or
something and if we click here on Prop
properties here we have a connection
string in this properties window which
I'm just going to
copy and put it here in the app
settings. Json
file just pasting it there I'm just
going to add another another thing here
so I set the encryption to false because
we don't have a password set to access
the database
basically and here we have created our
database and we have stored the address
in app settings. Json now if we go to
program.cs here we see that the service
is already
add uh is already added here so the
service for the uh for the context and
which also connects it the context to
the connection string as you can see
this
here and yes what we need to do is just
go to package manager console and add
the
migrations for the models that we
created okay so just add
migration and here I'm just giving a
name to the
migration
okay I think we've done a mistake in app
settings. Json so in app settings. Json
I think we have we're missing a comma or
something
there okay so uh we didn't close this
bracket here this was the problem so I'm
just going to need to add the migration
again and it is successful and just
going to update the database
now in the section we will create our
index next page we will firstly create a
controller and then we'll create a
service to get the data from the
database lastly we will also handle the
front end part by designing the index
view
page so uh firstly let's just go to the
controllers folder and add a controller
with views here so that we will have
some base methods uh let me just select
here the model of listing the context
and we'll just create it so that we have
some uh
boilerplate methods for the crowd
operations we won't use them exactly uh
actually we will create a service to get
the data from the database but just so
that we have some code in the beginning
that's why we're doing it
so okay so here we have our controller
with the
methods and in this video we will handle
the index method so for first let me
just go to the data folder and add a
folder for the
services just name it services and
inside here first we need a we'll create
a service an interface here so I'm going
to add the new item an
interface and I'm naming it I listings
service because we will get data for the
listings and here first we will just
create first select a signature method
that we will then Implement in the
services
class so uh the return timee will be of
I quable of
listing and I'm naming the method get
all so this will Implement then in the
new file that we'll create that I'm
going to be okay so I need to import
here the modeles
directory then I'm just going to add a
class and then we name a listing service
where we will implement this method
signature that we wrote
there so I'm just naming it listings
service click add and here we'll
implement the interface that we created
the IL listing service and if we click
here uh to show the areas we can click
here on Implement interface so that this
method is implemented
somehow
so so firstly let me just uh modify the
get all method let let's just try the
get all method and I copied it from the
controller what we had there and just
it's just as simple as this we're just
taking listings from the
context and we will include there the
users so that we will see the user
and for the context we will come here
and copy this what this what is here in
the controller and just paste it down on
top we just need to rename the
Constructor here to listing
service so we'll get the information
from database in this
service and the method is okay and now
here where we
had taken the context here we will
Import in the controller the service
that we just created so I listing
service and then we'll name this like
underline listing
service and then modify it here in the
con in the Constructor as
well okay and what we can do now in the
index method here we will take the
method that we created in the service so
here just write underline listings
service. get all which is the name of
the method that we have in this
service and that is basically how we'll
get the data for the listings in our
index
page I'm going to need to uh comment all
these other methods below because they
are using the context
and uh we now we are just using the
service in this controller so it would
have a lot of Errors if we let them as
they are so I'm just commenting out
everything except for the index method
which so that we can test it how it
looks like now when we go to program
that CS we need to add the service that
we created here so in the services
here the stri Builder that
services that add scope to as a scope
service and here we'll have to write the
name of the interface that we
created and the name of the service
itself
okay let just go to the listings folder
in the views folder and here at the
index. CSH
HTML I will just basically just change
the header here to an H2 header and
right here active listings to see all
the listings that are active in our
application and I guess I'm just going
to remove this table presentation here
here okay so I'm just going to delete
all of
this and I'm making a
forge Loop here to Loop through all of
the listings that we
have so for each V listing in the model
that is the listings
model
okay I guess I need to make it as an I
quable here because that's how the data
was when we wrote the method
before and here I'm going to have a div
container div of class container to
represent all of the objects all of the
things in this page I'm just giving it
styling as well the background color I
just saw it before for so I'm just
typing here the rgba code so I was just
testing it a little bit before and I
found the color and this is the code for
the
color
so I'm setting the margin on top to be
pixels and the margin on the bottom to
be also 50
pixels I'm giving it a
padding of like 20
pixels
and I'm giving it to the Border a radius
so it's like a corner
shaped and giving it the Border it is to
pixels okay so inside we need other div
I'm giving it the class for all which is
a bootstrap class and inside of it
will'll uh have another d with a class
of column so that we specify this way we
specify how many objects are in a row so
we make the class of column and then if
the screen is small the div will take
six out of 12 imaginary boxes of space
and if the screen is large the div will
take a bit less space it will take five
out of 12 imaginary boxes of space this
is just to make the page responsive
across different
devices
and here in
the we write for the images of the
listings here I'm just making this sign
here we will store the images in a
folder that we will create later that
will be in the root W ww root folder
you'll create the images folder there
and then we will
take the listing that image path which
will be the the address of the image
where the image is stored and for each
image we'll handle styling
here so the maximum width I'm setting it
to be something like 400
pixels and the maximum
height just is basically the same 400
pixels okay so I'm copying this to
have have another div
here this D will be a bit larger that's
how we specify the seven there and here
we have a H5 head inside of it we'll
have an anchor
tag which will redirect us to The
Details
page specify the route ID to be equal to
the models
ID okay I'm setting the color here
the color making it to be
black and inside the anchor here will I
put the listing the title so the title
of the
listing and just below we're going to
need another
div inside of it we just store the
description of the
listing uh okay so firstly here we need
to specify the listing
price which is how much is bided or
needs to be bided for the listing and
I'm making this two string uh method
here of n two so there there are two
numbers behind the after the comma so
when the number is 50 it will be
displayed like 50
comma and just below
there we'll just write here who listed
the listing so the owner so to say so
listing.
user do email but it's the same just
like the username I
think in our
case because the user's name we store
this an email actually so
yeah okay so here I'm going to make an
if
clause and in case there are there's
nothing in the model so the model is
empty there are no listings in our
database I'm just going to display it
here so that there are no active
listings so that's what basically we
have to to see first we want to load
that application now because we haven't
stored anything in the
database okay I think everything is okay
we have stored the service and
program.cs here we can just specify the
default controller to be the listings
controller so the around the application
it will appear the index of the lising
controller would be the first method to
be called the first link do we
call and we're just running the project
now okay we are um I think in the if we
go to the controller to the listens
controller here we uh return the view as
list the application context that to
list is seeing that's why we can't write
here I quable what I did but we just
leave it as it like list
iable so I don't know why I changed that
actually now uh yeah when on the
application this is what appears the uh
we see here that we have no active
listings so this is our index page but
when we store objects there will see
we'll see the listings when we'll start
listings there we'll see the
listings in this section we will handle
our create page we will see how we can
create the listings and during this we
will see how we can upload and store
files in our project such as image
files okay so let me just go to the
listings controller and uncomment here
this get create
method
I'm just going to remove this part here
because we don't need
it and I'm also going to need to
uncomment this post create method as
well but we'll modify it a lot there so
when we create the listings we're going
to need to get an image file from the
user and we will store it inside the
folder that we will create inside the
project for this reason we're going to
need a helper model that is similar to
the listings model but it does store the
images inside an iform file
property then we'll take the data from
this model and create a listing model
with it but instead of the iform file we
will store in the database the address
of the file in the image file string
property that the listings model
has so let us just create this model
firstly I'm just naming it listing view
model just as a
practice and then me go to the listing
model from here I'm going to copy almost
everything
I want to change the image Path property
later and I'm not going to use this bits
and Commons because I don't need them
when the user inputs the
data and here I'm changing this property
to I form file which accepts files
including images now name it uh like
image just image we need to import the
data annotations here for the require re
ired uh data
annotation okay so I'm going to go to
this www root folder and here inside I'm
going to add an images file which will
be the address where the images will be
stored when user stores it when a user
creates a
listing so if we go to the create uh. CS
HTML here we're going to need to modify
a few things to create the listing
so I'm just changing the header to
create
[Music]
listing I'm making it an H2 header and
on top I'm going to import a few things
so that we can get the uh user that is
currently loged in in the
application so firstly just add using
Microsoft
asp.net
identity I'm also going to need to
inject here the user
manager in the view
page so it takes an identity user and
I'll name it like user manager with a
small
U okay so
here uh we're going to need to write
encryption type in the
form and here we select multiart form
data which will be able to accept the
file the image that we will uh input
there here in the price when we take the
price in the label we can just write as
starting
bit here in the image path we're going
to rename it to image because now it
is it is a listing view model not a
listing model which had uh which has an
image
property changing it here as well but we
need to on top we need to make it say
listing view model not listing
model here in the input for the image I
need to specify also that it accepts
image so this line here we needed to
write
there and about the styling of
it can do
something so I'm just setting the width
of
30% of normal
form changing the image here
also right now for the eold property we
don't need to input anything here but we
need to make it that the
default value for the is sold property
to be false so uh listing is not solved
and this we can modify if we go to the
listing
model
and to listing view model as
well so here we need to make it equal to
false so when it is a listing is
created it is by default is not solved
so we'll need to modify it in the
listing view model as
well so here we need to don't need to
take any input for
that okay so here now we need to take
the currently logged in
user uh
so just put here an input tag it will be
of type hidden so yeah it's not shown in
the view page here in the sp4 tag we
need to specify identity user ID and we
need to select the value to it so it
will have the value of the currently
logged in
user so how we get the currently logged
in user we use user manager
do get user
ID of the user that is logged
in so that's the syntax how you write it
here in the view
pages
let me just around this here around the
project here to see specifically the
create view page how it looks
like there seems to be an error let me
just find
it okay so I would suggest the problem
is the create post
method because we haven't fixed it and
it has a context in
it but we take the information from the
controller we take the information from
the service so I think that's a
[Music]
problem then just go to the
controller yes so here I the area so I'm
just going to comment this out for a
minute and try to around the pro project
again and just go and to see the create
view
page see how this
looks okay I'm just going uncomment this
now so that we can handled what so we
saw how the form looked how the create
page looked but we'll see we'll handle
here how the input will be
handled so here we'll take a listing
view
model just name it
listing
so we're just making an if close here to
check if the listing that image is not
null so here we'll see we'll store it in
this images
folder so firstly to we need the
variable to specify the upload directory
which is going to
be
can get it by writing path.
combine you'll need to access
this address of the www root
directory which can be done using uh web
hosting
environment service which will will have
to include
actually in the Constructor of this
controller
so we'll combine this path with the
images folder so for this to work we
need to import it here in the
Constructor firstly we need
the we need the private trade only
variable for
it it's going to be I web host
environment I'll name it just like web
host
environment and this will get us the
address of this directory that we want
where the images are
stored just need to specifi it here
inside the Constructor as
well and back to the create method here
we need to specify here the we need the
variable for the file file
name how we can get this is by writing
listing that image that that
name that file name sorry this will get
the name of the file when we upload
it and the file path will be path.
combine this upload
directory together with the file
name so now we need to right here using
v file
stream right new file stream we will
create the new file stream class
here and inside we will specify file
path and file mode.
create which will basically basically
create a file for
us so this file stream initializes a
file stream class here is the path of
the image where the file stream file
will be created and here we specify that
we want to create a file in this file
mode that creat as we can read it
here so what is left for us do is here
right listing that image that copy
to file
stream and after we have created and
stored the file inside a project we will
create a listing object which will be
what will be stored inside our database
so we'll have this uh we'll create a the
new
listing the title of it will be the
title which was the listing view model
the
title so we'll take it from The View
model the same thing we we do for the
description as
well price equals listing the
price so so this listing was actually
the listing view model that we took from
the
[Music]
form the identity user ID will be
listing that identity user
ID and the image path will be this file
path that we have here
above so this is how the object is
created until this point
and here what left has to do is to
[Music]
return to return a direct to action to
index page so we'll return the user to
the index page until the form when the
form is
submitted
afterwards but right now we need to add
to have uh to create a function in our
service so that we can add this listing
to our database so we need a a method
that doesn't return anything which is an
a single we method and I will name it
add and it takes a
listing
object let me just go now to the listing
service and here it would appear an
error above and we need to click cck
Implement one moment yes here going
implement the
interface yeah I'm going to need to
write a
sync and we need to add this listing in
context that in the database by I think
contacts. listings. add listing and we
just need to save the changes to the
database so underline context. save
changes async and the method doesn't
return anything here we need to call
this method from the service that we
just wrote so wait underlines listing
service do add and we'll add there this
listing
object
and we have an error up there because we
haven't specified what happens when the
listing that image is
null so let me just return the user to
the same page where the user is so to
the create page together with the
listing a listing object okay let me
just turn the application now so we can
test
it we actually go to go to program. CS
firstly because when we need to register
user uh here the service right here we
need to specify require confirmed
account to
false so that when we register a
user uh it won doesn't need to uh verify
the account so it will be just created
instantly let we usually do it for our
purpose
okay let me just uh register a user
here I've run out of
names for
users just Jeff
gmail.com we need the password for
it
let's go the listings that
create I think I have a
watch in my
files starting we to I don't know 35 and
choose the file
here
okay choose this here here this
is think man's shirt was there so I'm
just changing this description
here okay so here here you see the
listing was created we see how the
design will be when we create a listing
in the index page so we see the title
the description the bit and the person
who made the
listing so what I also need to show you
is if we go to our images folder here
here we can see that when we created the
listing the image was uploaded in our
folder
here so basically yeah when a user
inputed the file there we created and
store the file inside this images
directory and then of course a new
listing was created with the image
path uh property so with the address
where the property where the F the image
file is saved and here in the index view
page we see that we take in the image
the source is
images uh at listing. image path so this
is how it is written from the database
the address of the
image this section will be about the
details page for each listing which is
the place where most of the
functionalities of the application are
actually written so we will specify how
a listing is displayed when we click on
it and we will also write some pieces of
logic about the display when specific
users see the
listing so firstly we need to uncomment
the
details method here in our in our
controller let me comment the text
here and I'm going to actually remove a
few pieces that we don't
need okay so all we need to do here is
to make this uh method here that
accesses the database we'll need to make
a method in the service
so here we we'll write the signature
firstly which will be an a synchronous
method it will return a listing and we
usually name it uh get by
ID and it will take an in ID as a
parameter so let me just go now to the
listing service and implement
this what we wrote in the
interface I'm just going need to write
the async
keyword
basically the logic here will be the
same as what we have
here so I'm just copying this
firstly and I'm just spacing it
here here I'm going also
add
here we I will also include the
comments and after
that I will also include the bits when
we take a listing from the context and
after including bids I'm actually going
to need for later use to then
include the users of that bit which I
make with this then
include method here
and of course after this I'm just going
to need to return this listing variable
here that's all we need to do in our
case here we just now need to remove
this here and use the method that we
just
created just so listing service. get by
ID and it takes the ID
above so just as a reminder we use we do
this methods in the service so that we
don't access the database from our
directly from our controller that's the
reason why we write these services and
then we import them in the
controllers we've talked about it uh
even before but just as a quick
reminder now let me just go to The
Details page where I'm basically just
going to remove all of
this and here's a part where you play
with the display of
stuff so here we'll just import the
Microsoft
identity to be able to access the
users here I'm going to inject to the
view page the user
manager which takes an identity
user I'll name it just user
manager I'm just going to remove that
here in the beginning we need I'm going
to make an
if close here so if the user that
identity that is authenticated so this
basically just says that if the
user is authenticated is logged in we'll
make some uh specifications in the
display and here what I'm basically
doing is just okay if the model is sold
so if model that sold is true we will uh
display a title in the listing so uh
depending from the status of the listing
so who is the winner or if the winner if
the user is the winner will displate as
you are the winner so first we need to
Loop through each bid in model.
bits so here basically if the bid. price
is equal to the model.
price so for the user who if the bid
that price is equal to model that price
then the user has had the highest bid
and here we specify if the bid. user ID
is equal to the logged in user the
current log user which we get with this
user manager. get user
ID basically what this is what this does
we will have a header here that says
congratulations you are the
winner so for this to be displayed the
user has to be logged in the the listing
has to be uh sold and
also the users bid has to have the
highest price from all the
bits and if not else if here we will
specify we will see if the logged in
user is actually the
person who made the
listing so if user man so if the
currently logged in
user is the model that I
user. ID so if the user has created the
listing itself it will tell the user who
the name of the person who won the
biding and if none of this
is uh is correct or
is for the case then we will just
display to a random user who opens the
the listing and if the listing is closed
he he will see just that the bidding is
closed so he won't see who won
it or if he is not the winner he won't
see uh any additional information so we
won't see who want it or of course he
won't see that he wanton it so um until
now we just made this functionality to
display a title in the listing on top of
the listing depending on who want it or
if the building is closed now we just
going to need to uh play around with the
display of the page of the listing so
I'm having a header here and I'm putting
the text Line to Center to center
it and here we have the title of the
model of the
listing yeah I would to need the
container div div class
container I'm giving the styling I'm
giving a background color which is just
a color I
was I saw before I was I just Mark the
values I'm just writing it here for the
color that I
wanted
so I'll give this div a bit of margins
on
top like 50
pixels and basically the same margin on
the bottom as
well
just some
paddings and I will make I'll in put
some border radius there to be so the
borders will have like corners on the
edges so
inside this div class container we're
going to need to copy some things from
the index
page CU some parts here uh will be like
the same have some same
structure so I copied that part from the
index view page and I'm pasing it here
but I need to adjust it a
bit so here I'll make the width to
100% of the width of the
image and the height to 60 view height
which is
the yeah 60% of the screen
basically and here we don't take it from
listing. image path but from model.
image
path okay that listing title we don't
need there because we have it on the
top here I'm just going to write that
model the
description and this I will actually
delete and here I will will specify some
conditions to how the foll the following
will be display so if the user is
authenticated
will make it possible for him to put a
bid there to bid something but if not
then
not so here I will make a
[Music]
form ASP action
which we haven't created this method yet
in the controller but I will just write
it here we'll create
later the method will be a post
method and here where the bid will be
displayed we'll make an input
there so the type of it will be number
so it takes only
numbers the minimum the minimum value of
it will be the model. price so you
cannot bid on lower than the model.
price and this step equals one just
means that there's like an option there
too so with the errors to increase it
with one or to decrease it with one the
price and the name equals price we need
this so we can so when the for when the
form will be
submitted and in the placeholder we
actually just store the model.
price that two
string and here specify n to which just
basically
will write the number with two numbers
after the comma so with two places after
the the
comma okay we just needed one single
input tag
there so together with the first input
when a bid will be submitted it should
take because the bid objects take a user
takes a listing so that's why we we
right here this input of type hidden
with the name of identity user
ID and the class of form
control so this will take the currently
logged in user that submits the bid and
the value that it takes will
be H will be will take it from the user
manager. get user ID of the currently
logged in
user so yeah I forgot this slash there
and just it's basically the same thing
for to get the listing ID as well so it
will be hidden
for the name here will specify actually
the name of the property which is
listing ID so that we need when we when
the form will be
submitted and here the value of it will
be just like at model.
ID here in the end we just need an inut
of
type
submit just class of form
control uh no sorry class of button and
button uh primary to be like a a blue
button we only needed an one single
input tag there as
well and this was it for the ad bit
form and Below there we can submit we
can display the number of bits
submitted in a paragraph and how we'll
take it is we will
take we'll write here model that
bits that count which is the method that
takes the number of bits that our module
has
I'm just Mak here this just like a line
to separate it from the next
thing and here we will specify so if the
from we'll take the currently logged in
user and if the user is actually the
person who the person who created the
bid
he will be only he will be able to see
the name of the people who have
submitted bids so if user manager. get
user ID equals to the model. user. ID he
will be able to see will list here all
of the names of the people who submitted
a bit and how much they
submitted so only the owner or the
creator of the listing will be able to
see this
for each so we'll take for each bit in
modular
bits so we write here an unordered
list of just specify The Styling here to
list style Type To
None not to have all of this default
list
stylings
here we'll take bit.
user that username so the username of
the user who have submit has submitted a
bid and we right here bid
it and the price the amount of the bid
so at
bid.
price that two
string PR this is and to so it will be
formatted a with the
Press yeah so that was it firstly for
this part so if the user is actually not
logged in now he won't be able to submit
anything so here I just need a div and
here I will just make an
import which will set it to disabled so
you cannot import anything there and
yeah won't do it inside the fors
because uh it won't take anything the
input I'm just copying this
here
so here in the input of type submit we
make it disabled so you cannot click on
the button on this submit
button so also right here if the user is
not plugged in he will be able to see
also the number of bits submitted for
that
listing
and here down below for to be able to
see by all we'll just write the name of
the
person who sub who listed the thisis
thing so mod model. user.
username then just copy this
here we need to use it again
so I just sced that part of code from
above so I will
just uh so this functionality will be
just for the owner of the listing the
person who listed it it will have an
will make it so the person who listed
the listing would be able to have this
anchor link here to be able to close the
bidding which is the method that will
create later this close speeding
method and it will take from in the aspr
out ID the model.
ID just naming it close
beding and we actually want to make it
so this person can only close the
building once the model that is
sold equals to false so if a person
actually closes the bidding the model
will be is that is sold will be true so
he cannot the idea is that he cannot
close the biding even after the mod the
biding was already closed and that after
the model was sold so after the listing
was sold he cannot close the bidding
then because it doesn't make
sense
here I'm just going to write
another of these lines to separate the
sections and here we're going to handle
the comments
actually
so if the user is authenticated so if a
user is logged
in uh he will be able to add a comment
to the
listing so just making it just we need
the container D
here and the form which will direct us
to an method that we'll also create
later to add comments and name get add
comment method will be
post and I'm going to have an uh
H6
header you can add a
commment actually we can we will store
the commment so the input will be a text
area actually so it's a bit bigger
and giving it a class of form control
for The
[Music]
Styling and this area
label with
text with text
area and the name of this text area will
be put it to Contex content so that we
can connect it to the when we'll create
later the comment as an
object and in a styling we'll put the
width to
40% and the vertical align to top so it
will be placed on
top on the upper
part
here we also need some input of type
hidden to have
the user that made the comment and also
to have the listing which we can copy
from here because so that we can create
a comment as an object we need these
two inut these two properties so to
say because a comment is also always
Associated to user to
listing and that's how we can add a
comment just making the styling of this
button
to so the display of
it just making it an inline
block and there's some margins to it
so in this else condition here else
close will just specify how it would
look like when the user is not
authenticated that and the user cannot
add the comment so I'm just copying this
here just REM moving the
form and this hidden inputs we won't
need
actually
and just will make the input here to
disabled so we cannot click it just the
same as we did when we added the
bid the only thing left now is here just
to display a way to
display a list of all the comments so
this was the form above how to add a
when we add the comment now we just need
to display the comments just a line
there to separate
this
and I'm just having another container
div Just For The
Styling or a bit of margins by
default and here
I just need a header to that say
comments and we need the forge Loop to
Loop all of the comments for that are
made in a listing so V comment in
model.
comments
and here in a
div which yeah we can make some styling
to it as well just will give it a
border will make the Border visible so
it will be one pixel
thick solid and light gray as a
color we'll set the margins to 10 pixels
and some padding as
well 10 pixel should be
enough and we'll just make the Border
radius we'll give it a border radius so
on the edges it will be like
rounded give a width of
40% and yes you can play around with the
CSS styling actually yeah just what I
was thinking how to do
it and inside here in a paragraph inside
paragraph tags we can input the comment.
content and we can just make it so that
we also see who post the comment like
the username
so add
comment. user not usern
name and I guess this was it this was
this should be
it if we don't have any
errors so now if we click on the title
here it should link us to The Details
page and this is how how it looks like
so yeah we can submit something there
but it won't work because we haven't
made the
add uh bit or add comment method yet but
this is how they would look like which
looks good to me that's how they are
displayed so here's the comment
section and here are the main
information about the
listing just now no bits are
submitted
if we going try to log out to see
how uh someone who is not logged in sees
this just go to listing
Index this details one and this is how
so this submit button is now not
clickable and this comment button is not
clickable but the other things the
persons that are not Lo the people that
are not logged in can see uh clearly can
see
okay in this section we will handle the
CSS of our application and the structure
of it we will handle the navigation menu
and the way it will be displayed and we
are also going to be adding some
complimentary features such as
pagination and the search bar after all
these modifications our auctions
application will look much cooler
visually and more user friendly so let's
just start working so firstly we need to
go to site. CSS file to make some
modification to the CSS of the
application so here we have some already
some styling to it by default and I'm
just going to be adding some extra some
padding in the body uh of the padding
will be of 10
pixels and I'm also going to specify
here the background
color which the one I'm choosing has uh
the following
codes now I'm just I'm also going to add
some stylings to the
navigation to the item with the
navigation class the background color of
it I'm just choosing it to be something
similar to the background color but Al
but of course to be a
bit
different and I'm also going to give
some border to the
navigation and it will be a one pixel
solid and and the color of it will be
black and now to the items that have the
nav link class I'm just making it I'm
giving them a color of
black and I'm also going to make some
styling here so that when we hover over
them they will turn the text of these
items will turn to
white just something to make them
visually a bit
better so color to
white just going around the application
to see how many of the changes are
saved okay so we see that the background
has changed the
color we see actually this this items in
the navigation are not
changing okay so let me just go to the
layout. Cs CSH HTML
file and here I'm going to we're going
to change the items that are in our
navigation so first we need to uh remove
these classes that are in this
navigation
class
so the color that there already was
would conflict with the color that we
inputed
ourselves okay so now we see that the
color of for the navigation is
[Music]
changed okay I'm going to remove
this button that that was
there we don't need something like that
so this icon thing that is by
default now I'm also going to change
this
items in the navigation so for the first
one I'll change the controller and the
name will be active listings because
this will redirect us to the listings
controller and to the index method
I'm going to also remove this uh class
here that specifies the color of this
navigation
items because that would conflict with
our own CSS for
it okay so we removed that icon what was
there in the
[Music]
beginning okay so what we're going to do
now is that some item in a navigation
will make them to be visible only when
the user is logged in so here I'm
writing at if user that identity does uh
is
authenticated then this menus that will
be here will only be displayed when the
user will be logged
in so let me just copy that first
one and
here I'm just going to change the method
here to make them to to redirect them to
the create method and here I'm going to
make the title to create listings so
only a user that is logged in can access
this
method this menu
item I'm just copying it
again
I'm putting like three menus three
navigation items here and the second one
here will redirect us to the m
listings uh method and the third one to
the my bits method which we will make in
the upcoming tutorials but basically
this will redirect us to a list of the
users
listings and the my bids uh method will
redirect them to a list of
uh to the listings which they have ped
for we'll specify how this methods work
later but just to have them there uh
visually that's why we are doing them
now in this navigation item we will
actually input the search bar which will
make it to be right in the middle of our
navigation
menu and for it actually I'm going to
need the library from the font aom this
a page that allows us to have some
pretty cool
icons inside our
projects so this was the page but we
need to go to the
library and we need to copy the link tag
here and input it in the
header so that now we can use the cool
icons that this Library
offers and for it firstly here we're
going to use it here because we're going
to input a search icon and this will
also of course the search input we're
going to need to have a form here so
that whatever is inputed in the in this
sech and this sech input will be
redirected to the listings controller
and to the index
method specifying the method here to get
because that's how we do it in a when we
make the search
functionality when we search for items
when filter items
here I need an input
tag so I'm giving some styling to
it just making the width of it
to
80% the remaining 20% will be covered by
the surge button slash
icon I'm going to float this to the left
and here I'm giving it a radius to the
Border top
left on the top left
border and in
the bottom left border I'm giving it a
radius as well so it will be like around
it
began color I'm setting it to white
smoke okay I've mispelled it the float
there I've actually made a specific
video on how to make this
exactly this exact search bar which I'm
going to be linking down in the
description and here I'm going to
specify the type that it accepts will be
on the
text and the name I'm giving it the name
like search
string and the class I leave it as form
control so down below we're going to
need we need a
button to submit
what to be able to submit the
data and I'm giving it a styling of the
width I'm saying it to 20% the float I'm
going to float it to the
left and
the Border will be set to none we won't
have any
borders I'm making the background to
transparent and the height of the button
will be 40
pixels and of course we need to specify
here the type of the button to be submit
here we're going to write what will be
displayed in the button and here comes
our icons from f, library I'm giving it
a class of fa and Fa search which is
basically just a search
icon we're actually going to input icons
in each of these navigation
items because they will look very much
very much better visually so to to the
active
listings I'm going to give it an icon of
fa fa solid
and
Fa
house you can see this on the font aome
uh website the codes for many different
icons but I've so them before and I'm
just imp putting them here now to save
some
time so to the create list thing
navigation
item I'm giving it the class of fa fa
solid and Fa plus so it's going to be
this plus
sign the my
listings I'm going to change it the
class to fa newspaper
here and in the last one in the my bits
navigation item
the class will be fa fa solid and Fa Sac
dollar so we're just turning the
application to see how it looks until
now
visually of course need to be loged in
to see more things but we can see this
search bar here which looks pretty cool
in my
opinion and the active listings with the
sideon
when we hover over the navigation items
they should be white as we specified in
side. CSS but okay we had to write do
Nev link to specify that this is a
class and if we refresh now we can see
that if we hover over this navigation
item it will turn to White if we can log
in we would be able to see the other
navigation
items
so let how they seem that's how they
look when we hover over
them and until now we only have active
only the first two navigation items and
we have to implement the functionality
for the search bar as well which we
haven't
down I'm actually going to open up a
project as I said I will link down below
how we can add the search functionality
in our project but I will just take the
code from my for project
here and I'll will explain you what I'm
going to do be
doing so this was my for
application firstly I will actually copy
the code for the pagination
functionality because we are going to
implement them both and for both of them
we need to modify the index method and
I'm going to link down in the
description below the video where I
explain ping ation more in
detail basically we need to add a class
paginated list class in our
root
directory okay I'm naming a class here
generated list. Cs and I'll input there
everything that I copied from my Forum
project this is okay I'm just going to
change the name space here to the name
of the project and this you could find
in the Microsoft documentation as well
this exact paginated list class but let
me just go back to the
controller here and we're going to need
to modify the index method as
well let me see here in our previous
project okay so this is the structure we
take a number we take a number for the
paginated
list and this is how the view will be
returned and we need a page size there a
page size variable there let me just
copy the first two
firstly so basically yeah we have a page
size how many items we want to be in a
page
and then we return this pated list class
with the items from our
context in the parameter we need
an page number in parameter to know in
which uh in which page we are and we
also need this search
string parameter if in case the user
inputs something in the search
bar so we'll take the items from this
application DB context variable in this
application DB context variable we are
setting the page size to
three of course we're taking the page
number and the search string form the
parameter and here we actually make an
if close in case
the search string is not
null so if an user has inputed something
in the search
string so here in the application DB
context variable we are searching with
thisare
function we're searching for the items
where the title contains
this search
string basically that's what it does and
here we need to return a view
here and here below we need to make the
change it to listing
there and in application. DB context
here we need
to
specify that we want
listings that are not sold
we could do this later St listings where
do is sold is equal to false so in the
first page will only appear those
listings that
aren't where the bidding is not
closed and we could do it later but I'm
doing it right now since we are handling
the index method one more
time and I'm just covering what we have
here and the exact same thing will be
returned in case the user inputs
something in the search bar but the
difference will be
that uh the listings will contain the
title that was uted in the search
bar if we seen in our previous project
we also need
this on top of the page we need to use
paginated list and here we need this
variables and this HTML Elements which
which basically are just this buttons on
on the bottom of the page that we can go
from one page to another so from the
first page to the second page and so on
and I'm just in putting them here in our
index. CSH HTML file and on top of it
I'm making the model so we are importing
a page list
model we are using a pated list
model and if we're on the application
now we should see all of our
changes okay we can see
here let it just load we can see here
this uh pagination implemented but we
only have one page and we can see that
the search bar is
functional if we type their shirt our
listing will appear but we only have one
listing so we can do
much uh experiments with
that in this section we will Implement
how to add bids and how to close the
bidding in our application we will write
the methods in the controller for both
of these functionalities and we will
also going to need to create a bits
service so let me just firstly go to our
Details page to see where we have added
the form to add the
bidding and let me just find it so here
we have this form where uh the user can
input a bit but this add bit method we
haven't written anywhere yet so we need
to implement that in our uh in our
listings
controller so I'm just writing it right
here
somewhere so this will be an http post
method so as usual public async it will
be an asynchronous weight
method public async
task it takes it returns an action
result and I'm naming it we'll name it
ad bid and what will write here inside
side we will bind here the what we will
take from our form so we write here the
ID that we take from the form the
price of the bid the listing
ID and the identity user
ID and in
the and we here need to specify also
that we are we are taking a bit
object from the
form so firstly we need to check if the
model state is
valid and if that is the
case here will will basically store that
bit in our data
based but to do that we will actually we
don't we we'll actually need to create a
service to get the bids so a service
like service bits. add and then we'll
add the bit but now we need to actually
create this service because it doesn't
exist and let me just go to this
Services folder here and firstly add a
new item to add an ibits service
interface
press enter and here we need to write
the method signature uh this will be an
a sing weight method it's doesn't return
anything the name is ADD and it takes a
bit in the
parameters now we need to go to the
services folder and add the bits
service
so like new
class bids
service and this will
implement the ibit
service
interface here we implement the
interface there and we'll need
to access the cont context which I'm
copying it from the I list from the
listing service so just this Constructor
and this variable that where we store
the
context just going to need to rename the
Constructor
here so this way we will we just take
the cont the a variable with the context
and this here in the in our ad method we
just need to write underline context
bits. add we will add the bid to our
context and we just need here to await
to write away then then to save the
changes to our database with this save
changes async method so this method
doesn't return anything so it's good now
and in our listings controller we need
to have a variable here for the bits
service just like that a PR
only I bit service and I'll give a name
for the
variable just like I've done there above
bits
service and we also are going to need to
write this to write this service in the
Constructor as well
there and
here so now we have access to the
service that we created in the
controller let me just go to the program
that says here and add the
service that we just created We'll add
it as a scop service and here we specify
the name of the
interface we always need to do this each
time we create a service to go to
program.
Cs and now back to the add bid method in
our
controller here the name of our service
actually we made it to be bits
service and now here we
are going to need
to take the list
thing and here now we are going to need
to have a variable where we will store
the
listing where the bid was made
so underline listing service. get by
ID
bit. listing ID so we'll
just we just need the listing where this
beding was
made so now we can take the listing that
price and set it to the bid. price so to
the
new bid that was made to that listing
that's why we needed the listing
variable and we need to save this
changes to the database and we actually
need this to do this by this context.
save changes say sync but since we
manipulate data in the context we just
need to create another method there just
like a save changes method it doesn't
take anything it doesn't return
anything let me implement this in the I
listings in the listing
service I'm just making it
async and here we just just need to
write wait save underl
context that save changes
ASN so now we
can use this method in the
controller so that the change of the
price of the listing will be changed in
the dat database as well so here we just
write await listing service. save
changes and now we can just
turn
View and return the user to The Details
page and we can input here the listing
so it takes
The Details page will be for that
listing the details method takes a
listing
so yeah we need an listing object there
when we return the
view and that was it for the ad bid
method we now can also write the close
bidding
method so public Asing task
the3 action
result the name of it will let it as it
was close
bidding and it takes an in ID
parameter if we go to The Details page
let me see where we have it here so yeah
we have a anchor tank here to be able to
close close the bidding which can only
be done by the person who posted the
listing and here we need to take the
listing where
the that has the ID that we take here in
the parameter and we will set that
listings uh so the isol property of that
listing we are going to need to set to
true so that means that the listing is
sold now we can just use this save
changes method to save the changes to
the
database and we can
return the users to The Details
page of that
listing okay so let me just refresh it
here okay there seems to be an
error okay I was having an error because
here when I declared this service in the
program. Cs I declared the interface
twice so if I run the application
now we can go now and try these
functionalities that we implemented we
actually is good to uh register another
users so that one makes the Bings and
the other one can close
them
just a name and a password
there if we click on this listing here
they can just try to add the bid and
submit it and as you can see now the new
price for the bid uh for the bid the new
price that can be bided is $37 now so
the add bid method meod worked fine
worked very well if we log in with the
other user
now we see here that the owner can see
who made the bidding and how much he
made so we see there and if we we close
the biding
now so if the owner tries to close the
buildings the winner will appear on top
there as we can see here what we WR on
top of the details page the name of the
winner will appear on the owner's page
but if the user has won the bidding it
will appear the line of congratulations
you are the winner so this should appear
on the other accounts
page so on Sean's account he if he opens
the bidding if he opens the listing he
should see only that he should see that
he is the winner so if we try to log in
with the
Shan
account okay we won't see anything here
because we changed the index page so
that it shows only the active listing so
the listing is not active anymore
because now it is sold so let me just
comment this out here that shows in our
index
page
only active
listings I uncommented the wrong line
there we should uncomment the line where
the user hasn't inputed something in the
search bar so this here and actually
when we'll Implement later on the my
listings and my bits method
the user will be able to see his own
bits and his own listings in a separate
tab so we don't have to change it
here so this procedure that we're doing
here won't be necessary
then okay the so now if the user opens
it he sees that he won you are the
winner so Shan on the
bidding
in this section we will handle the
functionality of adding comments to the
listings we will firstly create the add
comment method in our controller and we
will create the comment service in order
to interact with a
database so let me just firstly go to
our project and I'm going to open up the
details
page uh here I'm going to I'm trying
just find the form where we add the
comments so here's our form where the
users can input the comments and we have
to create this add comment method in our
controller so if we go to the listings
controller just somewhere here I'm going
to write here the method as an HTTP post
method and here the usual public
async t
TK it returns an action
result and the name of it is ADD comment
of
course here then we are going to bind
what we take from the form to this
method so I'm going to write inside here
the
ID that we take for from the form the
content of the
comment the listing
ID and the identity user
ID and here we specify that we are
taking a comment object from the
form here we then make the check if the
model state is
valid and if that's correct we will need
to store the comment in the database for
that we need to await to write the await
keyword and here we need a
method to be able to add the commment to
our database but for this reason we're
going to need to create a comment
service because we haven't created any
yet so here in the services folder
firstly I'm going to need to add an
interface which I'm going to name I
comments
service here we going to have to specify
the signature method for our add method
so task
add and it takes a
comment in the
parameter doesn't return
anything now to the services folder we
add a class which we are going to name
comment
service here on top we first need to
implement our interface that we just
wrote and here on the errors we need we
can click on Implement
interface but on top of the page let me
just go to the listing service and copy
just what we do usually here we need to
uh get this variable and the Constructor
in order to get access to the context
and I'm just going to modify here the
name of the Constructor to have the name
of our
service and in the add method I'm
writing there
async
keyword and here we can just write
underline
context.
comments. add the comment and then we
just need to save these changes to the
database and this method doesn't have
the need to
return
anything let me just go back to the
controller
now and we need to write here a variable
that takes this
service so I commment service and I'm
naming it underline commments
service we need to store the service to
declare it also here in the
Constructor just like we've done with
the previous services that we've
created so in program.cs as usual we
need to declare the service we're making
it as ADD as scoped
service and inside here we write the
name of the interface SP and the name of
the service now we just need to go back
to the
controller and continue with our add
comments
method so here we' added the
comment and we here need a variable to
store the listing from where we are
taking the
comment so wait listing
service. get by
ID and this takes the
comment. listing
ID so we're taking from the
database the listing where the comment
was
made
this is comments. listing
ID comment listing
ID and now we can return The View with
this ex of we can return the view of the
details page for this exact
listing so what's left for us to do is
we can run the application and and check
this
functionality if I click on this
listing can try and edit the comment and
add the comment here like did I win I
don't know we could ask about the
listing actually and here we see the
comment and the user who posted the
comment and actually try here with the
owner's account of that
listing which was
Jeff and I can return a comment to the
user who
asked and see how it appears so yes you
did submit and we see that
Jeff replied to that
comment in the section we will see how
we can display the specific listings
that the user has made we will only need
to create the method in our controller
and this can be accessed by the user
from the navigation
menu so let me just open up our
controller and we can make this method
just below the index method because they
have a similar structure and I'm copying
this
firstly and pasting it just right below
that I will change the name to my
listings and I'm actually not going to
make the search functional I'm not going
to need the search functionality for
this method so I'm going to delete this
part and this lines here as well but
we're going to have we're going to use
the
pagination here uh the only difference
that's going to be is that when we
return the view we will return the index
View and
also let me just uncommon this part here
because we in the index method we need
to show only the method only the
listings that are not
sold and in our listings method we will
show every listing that the using that
the user has made
including the sold
ones so here we can write this dotware
method where we will specify that we
want to display only
listings where the user ID where or
where the user is equal to the currently
logged in user so l. identity user ID
equals user
do find first
value and
inside the brackets where I claim
types do name identifier with this line
here only what it does is just takes the
ID of the currently logged in user this
is how we get the idea of the currently
logged in user in the
controller and this is all we're going
to need for this method now if we run
the
application and we click on the my
listings from okay firstly when we run
the application we won't see this
listing anymore because it is
sold the listing is sold as we did in
the previous video when we close the
bidding okay I'm just running it one
more
time
so we won't be able to see any listings
in the first page but when we go to my
listings we will see all of the listings
that this user has made
before in this section we will see how
we can display the specific listings
that the user has bided for we will need
to create a method in the controller as
well as a service to get the bits from
the database then we will create a New
View page which the user can access from
the navigation menu so let me just go
back to the
project and here under my
listings method I'm going to copy them
and I'm going to right here my bits
method this they have a similar
structure but also they are different
which we will see
here so the first thing that I'm going
to do
here we will get the data from the bit
service and not from the listing service
because we'll get a list of bids and we
haven't created this method yet so if I
go here to the ibit service interface
I'm going to need to create this get all
method which will return an i variable
of bits and it will have the name of get
all and if I go to the then to the bits
service let me just Implement that
method here that the
interface and let me just remove it
here and inside this variable I'm going
to get the data from the context
so we'll use this link query to get the
data from the context so from a in
underline Contex context.
bits we will include in the
context a few things so firstly for the
bits we will need to
include the
listing because we will then Show the
listings and if we add then include we
can take the
users of that
listing and there we select it select a
and we will just need to
return this
variable that's just how
we let just all for the get all method
and here as we we have written it here
we have taken the data here in the
method from the
service the difference here is that when
we will return a page unated list of
bits and we'll take the
bits that a user has
created and here in the when we return
the view we will return the view for the
my
bits which we will create now The View
page for my
BDS so we are just adding a view
here just an empty
view which I'm going to need to have to
name the same as the name of the
method so my
bits and for this I'm actually going to
copy the index page but but I'm going to
make a few modifications to
it so I'm just going to copy the whole
index page and I'm pasting it
here we have here a list of
bids and here in the for Loop I'm
changing it to bit we'll take the bits
and we'll get the same information that
we get in the index page but we will
access them by writing here at bid
listing. image path for example and for
all of the others so here we will take
the listing ID by writing at bid.
listing. ID and this way we'll take the
title of the listing that the user has
bided for so at bid. listing.
Title Here we right at bid. listing the
description so by using the bid we will
access the
listings that the user has bid it
for here as well we'll access the
user the listings user by the
bids I'm I'm just changing this
paragraph here
to no bits made or just no
bits Rel leave the HTML for the
pagination as it
is and if I run the application
now
okay if I go to my
bits as I remember it's correct we can
see we actually bid it for this so and
we are actually the winnner so we can
see this listing by accessing the
bits you can just go to the my bits view
page here I'm just going to change the
the title here to just my
bits and this way we can see that we
access our bits by in this
page so we have come to the end of the
section and this was also the last
functionality that we needed to add to
complete our auctions
application we have come to the end of
this YouTube series we created a
complete application in asp.net core and
learned how to build the useful auctions
application we did play around with
different functionalities like adding
bits adding comments closing the bidding
creating listings Etc we also tried
different things in the front end in
order to display specific data depending
on the user that was logged in and we
worked on implementing various features
to the same project or to the same page
in case you have a based knowledge and
know how things pretty much work in any
language or framework it is important to
try and build projects with a degree of
complexity you will learn a lot just by
putting all that you know together and
by solving new things that come up
during the way that's why I would
recommend you to try and add new
features to this auctions application or
change the way things are displayed in
certain places then you would actually
realize how much you really known and
how much you understand how the entire
application works I was thank you very
much for watching and I would really
appreciate it if you subscribe to the
channel and like the video in case you
enjoyed the whole series thank you and I
will see you in the next
one